hey what is up everybody it's anna mack
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the latest twist
in the boku no hero story including the
appearance of
deku's game changing new power
and no i'm not just talking about his
new quirk related power
i'm also talking about something
potentially even more groundbreaking so
stay tuned because
this is huge if you enjoyed the boku no
hero content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going just leave a like
and comment it only takes a second but
it actually helps a lot
and of course if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
but you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications okay now a quick
thank you to afk arena for sponsoring
this video
afk arena is a rewarding casual and
strategic mobile online rpg with a
unique art style and
epic fantasy elements afk arena allowed
me to build my dream team of heroes and
go on amazing adventures without forcing
me to grind for hours on
end when i downloaded the game i was
just gonna check it out for a few
minutes and then play again later
but the game is so engaging and
rewarding that i ended up playing for
like an
hour before i even realized what time it
was collect
100 heroes for free and go on an
adventure with them while making use of
the seven different factions
and their unique skills to create
strategic brilliance
i love my ascended hero izold he's like
this crazy mixture of a magical knight
and frankenstein's monster
he's old is definitely part of my dream
team he'll absolutely crush
in battle afk arena is stress free and
free to play
to celebrate their second anniversary
between april 6th
and may 5th every player will receive
100 free summons
and one special gift code the bonuses
they're offering are unprecedented don't
miss this chance click the link in the
description for your chance to build
your dream team with 100 free
summons download afk arena today it's
the best time to start playing
and by downloading the game you are
supporting this channel just click the
link in the description
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been
warned okay so in the previous chapter
an epic rematch between deku and the
overpowered villain muscular
was set up and in the latest installment
of the story that rematch
escalated quickly as soon as deku
rescues shindo from muscular's clutches
muscular recognizes midoriya the villain
remembers deku well
since deku was the one who took him down
last time
so muscular knows its deku even though
he is wearing that new
badass mask over his face but
instead of being angry at deku for
putting him in jail
muscular is just excited to see him
again he actually says that he missed
deku so much and he can't wait to take
him on
once again muscular doesn't want to make
some grand speech about revenge
he's not really a master schemer and he
doesn't have any grand philosophy that
drives his actions
muscular just likes to use his
overpowered quirk to do whatever he
wants
and right now he wants to stop fighting
all the small fry and take on someone of
deku's caliber
now deku's big problem is that he can't
fight muscular until he gets shindo to
safety
deku is still holding an injured shindo
in his arms so he has to find a way to
avoid muscular's attacks for long enough
to safely evacuate shindo
as deku makes his getaway he notices
that muscular
isn't jumping directly at him instead of
attacking deku directly
muscular is targeting the building on
top of which deku had been standing
but thankfully deku manages to leap off
of the building and he eventually
locates
tatami tatami sees a whole bunch of
smoke and then someone hands
shindo over to her tatami is in tears
when she sees the extent of shindo's
injuries
but she's also happy that he is alive in
case you didn't know
the official mha character guide
confirms that shindo and tatami are
dating they're a couple
so it's no surprise to see tatami being
so emotional over what happened to
shindo
out of the heavy smoke that surrounds
them deku calls out and tells tatami to
take care of shindo
and to be careful because the collateral
damage is through the roof
but despite this chaotic and dangerous
situation
deku vows that there will be no more
casualties from this point onward
he will put a stop to muscular tatami
can't actually see deku because of all
the smoke
but she notes that his voice sounds
familiar this makes sense because tatami
met
deku before back during the provisional
hero license exams
and it is at this point that one thing
becomes
clear all that smoke around deku isn't
just the result of the collateral damage
caused by muscular's destruction sure
muscular's assault on multiple buildings
definitely created a bunch of dust and
smoke
but this is something else deku has
unlocked a brand new quirk
the sixth one for all user n the
predecessor of nana shimura
appears next to deku and begins advising
him on how to use his own quirk
and the name of that quirk is
smokescreen
as the name suggests smokescreen allows
deku to generate a bunch of smoke that
conceals his presence from his opponent
and deku was able to use this ability to
take shindo to safety and cover his
tracks
because muscular was unable to tell
where he was because of all the smoke
and it tells deku to be careful and to
stop relying too much
on one for all since this is a mistake
that the previous 8 users
made in the past and tells deku not to
let one for all's power
use his body instead his body must learn
to use
one for all deku cannot allow one for
all or any other single quirk to be his
only strategy in battle
and he can't allow the power of one for
all to run rampant
inside his body because that will hurt
his body in the long run
according to n the quirks of the
previous users alone
are not enough to make deku successful
he cannot rely on them too much and he
must not
use them as a crutch these quirks are
just tools
in his arsenal and deku must learn to
use the right tool
at the right time deku then uses float
in combination
with full cowl to leap over the smoke
and get a bird's eye view
of the situation as muscular attacks him
deku uses smoke screen to reduce
muscular's vision
and then he uses danger sense to avoid
muscular's attacks
this is actually a really useful
combination of quirks when you think
about it
smokescreen severely reduces the
visibility for deku's opponent
but thanks to danger sense deku still
knows exactly where his opponent is
despite all the smoke now combine those
two quirks with one for all's own power
with float and with black whip
and you have deku effectively dodging
and counter-attacking against muscular
to the point that even muscular gets
frustrated with all the tricks that deku
has up his sleeve
don't forget that the last time muscular
fought deku deku couldn't yet
use any of the former users quirks so
this really is a whole new deku as far
as muscular
is concerned deku then tries to talk to
muscular
in between all the fighting he basically
tries to talk no jutsu him
and he asks the villain where shigaraki
and all for one went
after they freed him from tartarus but
muscular replies that he doesn't know
and he doesn't care
all for one told him to do whatever he
wanted to do with his newfound freedom
and that is exactly what muscular has
been doing
this is a bit of a surprise to me
because i thought that all for one would
want muscular to be his henchmen
but maybe all for one wants muscular to
just keep the heroes as busy as possible
by destroying as much as possible
for his part deku wants to keep talking
because he wants to understand muscular
and how a villain like him thinks why
does he do
what he does why does he have the urge
to go on these destructive rampages that
hurt so many people
deku thinks that maybe if he could truly
understand a villain like muscular
and where he is coming from maybe he
could change things
maybe he could convince him to stop the
destruction without anyone else
getting hurt if only deku could learn to
understand
these villains maybe he could even get
through to shigaraki and help him change
his ways
but muscular has no interest in all the
talk no jutsu he tells deku to shove
all his therapy talk somewhere else and
he explains that he simply loves
blood guts and the thrill of the battle
it's not about some deep philosophy for
him it's not about some tragic backstory
it's not about good or evil it's not
about right or wrong
he just loves violence he loves to fight
and he wants to keep doing it regardless
of the consequences
and regardless of the collateral damage
that he causes despite
this answer it seems that deku still
hasn't given up on the idea of getting
through to shigaraki by reaching the
deepest crevices of his soul
even though shigaraki has done
absolutely horrible things deck who
still believes that he can
save him without killing him i think
dekku is absolutely wrong on that point
but either way
before he faces shigaraki again deku
will have to finish
this fight with muscular although this
does make me
think if deku is trying so hard to
understand the villains and where
they're
coming from does this mean that at some
point he's going to get closer to stain
because stain is kind of a villain but
also a vigilante who wants to do good
things just in a really twisted way
i mean maybe i'm just reaching because i
want to see deku and stain working
together
so badly but i think stain might end up
being a sort of
case study for deku when it comes to
understanding the villains
luckily for deku it appears that
muscular suffered some serious
tendon damage when shindo used his
vibration quirk against him
earlier the damage didn't take full
effect right away
but now deku can see that muscular's
tendons were pulled
and they are now beginning to unravel
this is why muscular didn't
jump directly at deku earlier on in the
fight
his muscles were already feeling the
strain and he was unable to reach deku
directly so he went
after the building that deku was
standing on in the final panel of the
chapter
deku smashes muscular with so much force
that it looks like he punched a hole
straight through his muscle fibers and
as the mask
flies off deku's face the chapter
ends wow that was crazy
not only did we get to see deku using a
new quirk but we also got to see him
using all of the quirks that he has
unlocked so far
in order to produce some incredible
strategic combos
he used smokescreen danger sense float
black whip and of course one for all
itself in an absolutely
seamless and strategically brilliant way
and it seems that
thanks to these strategic combos deku
has been able to take out muscular
yet again to be fair it seems that
shindo had already weakened muscular
but still we simply cannot underestimate
the strength and raw power
of this new deku all his quirks when
used together as a combo
have so much potential definitely let me
know what you thought of the new quirk
smoke screen and did you like how deku
was able to combine
all the quirks during this battle i
thought that this was a great sign
of things to come we are definitely
going to see deku combining
all of his different quirks in awesome
new ways a lot more regularly from now
on
but i also have to talk about the other
new power that deku seems to have
unlocked a power
that i think might be a much bigger deal
than smoke screen itself
i mean sure smoke screen is obviously
useful in battle especially when used in
combination with the other quirks
and smoke screen may also have some
other awesome aspects to it that we
haven't discovered
yet but the fact that n the original
user of smokescreen
was able to emerge from the vestige
world and straight up talk to deku and
give him advice in real time during the
battle
is huge does this mean that deku can now
call upon any of the former users to
emerge from the vestige world and advise
him at any time
instead of having to deal with traveling
to the vestige world and speaking to
them there
is deku now able to just get advice
anytime he wants
even in the middle of a battle i mean
maybe this was just a unique way of
showing a flashback in which
anne had told deku all of these things
in the past but
by the way that end was shown right next
to deku and talking to him about
everything that was happening
as it happened it really looked like
anne was advising deku
in real time if this is what really
happened
it is absolutely crazy think about it
every time deku uses one of his quirks
the original user could appear next to
him and tell him the best way to use the
quirk in any given situation
that would be so freaking useful for
deku and it would speed up his training
immensely to me the ability to
potentially summon the vestiges and
speak to them in real time
during a battle is an even crazier
power-up than unlocking a new quirk like
smokescreen
but let me know how you guys feel about
this was this just a flashback that was
drawn in a creative way
or did ant really emerge from the
vestige world and give deku pointers on
how to use smokescreen
in real time don't forget to leave your
feedback down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this boku no hero video
and you want to see more
just leave a like to let me know it only
takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and
instagram at anime uproar thanks again
to afk arena for sponsoring
this video check them out right now by
clicking that link
in the description and build your dream
team with 100 free
summons as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you